hello and welcome to Google developers
live I'm Paul saxman a developer
advocate at Google and I work with the
Google Maps API is like most people I
love well-designed Maps as much as I
like great looking websites so in this
show I'm going to share some additional
resources and techniques for creating
and using custom map styles with the
Google Maps JavaScript API we've already
shared a few ideas and a bit of
information about map styling in a
previous video specifically the one
reference in the video description below
after you're done here be sure to watch
this show for some additional map
styling techniques one excellent
resource however that didn't exist when
this video was recorded as snazzy Maps
snazzy Maps is a community driven
repository of map styles for the Google
Maps JavaScript API the site contains a
number of high quality beautiful and
useful map Styles so if for example
you're looking for a subtle light pastel
style for your own map on your own
website
snazzy Maps is a great resource for
styles and in perspiration it's not to
say that the default Road map style for
the Google Maps API is hard to look at
especially since the vision the recent
visual refresh however there are a
number of reasons why you should
consider adding a bit of custom style to
your own map for example map styling
allows you to create a map that matches
your website's brand and style you can
see that the designers of the Rough
Guides web site chose to match the map
style to their company logo also if you
have a specific purpose for the map such
as showing roads and geography for
context but not labels or the default
Pio is you can use map styling to
simplify hide or highlight specific map
features this is how the beautiful and
fun ABI 'putin ski website uses map
styling
and finally a big reason that data geeks
and analysts like my selves and our
friends at Carter DB use map styling is
for overlaying their own data on a map a
Sidhu subdued or simplified map style
allows you to keep the user focused on
your data to ensure that they're not too
distracted by the default map features
back to snazzy Maps when choosing a
style for your map it's important to
check the style at it the zoom levels in
geographic regions that you intend to
support on your own website
snazzy Maps allows you to do this by
synchronizing the zoom of all the maps
in the list and they're even
synchronized if you page to the next
page or you go to the next page and
likewise
they're also synchronized if you go to a
particular style this site was designed
as a resource for both developers and
designers so you're not only able to
browse the snazzy maps you can also find
code to include in your own website
which is below on the details page if
you already using them out the Maps
JavaScript API and you want to use one
of the styles from snazzy Maps all you
need to do is use the style code here
this is in the JavaScript sky larae when
you create a map options object you can
actually apply the style like we see in
this code here if you don't already have
a map in your application you can use
this javascript code here all you do is
you import it in put it in your style
tag you likewise have to make sure that
you've bootstrap the JavaScript API all
documented on our website and I'll put
the link below but finally if you don't
have a map or an existing web page you
can download a self-contained sample
HTML file with a working styled map
that's this link here I'm going to
download some code keep that guy and you
can see if I run it I actually have the
exact same map as we saw before let's
take a look at the code one thing that
you're going to want to keep in mind if
you use this code is that you're going
to have to eventually actually put in
your Google Maps API key that's
documented very well right here and
likewise you know you'll see a lot of
documentation in this code so if you
actually want to style or tweak this
implementation
it's very well documented and very easy
to do let's go back to snazzy maps so
the styles on the side are licensed
under creative commons share-alike
that's over here which means that you're
free to use these styles even for
commercial purposes however be sure to
provide attribution and share any
derivative styles preferably on snazzy
maps to contribute a style back to
snazzy Maps you'll need to fill out this
form all the way up here you can use one
of these tools listed here like a styled
Maps API wizard the custom google map
style tool or Google Maps colorizer to
actually create your own style I covered
the style Maps wizard in previous show
the one that I mentioned earlier so if
you're interested in creating your own
style definitely check out that show and
speaking about attribution the snazzy
Maps site was developed by Adam Krogh a
tap mist and so be sure to follow atmost
on Twitter Facebook and Google+ all the
links are down here for updates on the
site or to give them a +1 for building
such an excellent web app they
definitely deserve it this is a really
cool tool a really great resource for
developers Adam and the Atmos team are
planning to add more features to the
site including a style designer accounts
and favorites if you have ideas that you
want to share with Adam and company four
features for the site I just click on
the ever-present feedback button here on
the left you can see it's already
pre-populated you can vote and provide
your own feedback as well if you do
create your own snazzy map style also be
sure to let the Google Maps API team
know you can reach us on Google+ and
Twitter and with that thanks for
watching and happy map styling have fun